and right off the bat let's talk to the
guy who jump started the
portland trail blazers in the fourth
quarter carmelo anthony joins us uh
melo thank you for your time i
i see that going into the game after
passing oscar robertson you were 224
points behind akeem the dream
it looked like you were trying to catch
him in the fourth quarter alone tell me
about your fourth quarter when you
scored 17.
i'm just playing just enjoying the game
playing taking advantage of my
opportunities
you know i didn't play much in the third
i stayed with it stuck with it
uh chaired my teammates on when my
number was called i
i was ready to deliver carmelo you know
your team
i'm a big fan of your team do you how
frustrated are you guys that y'all can
have
never all get healthy at the same time
it's tough
it's tough it seemed like portland got
it got the jinx out here but
let them get let them get right there
they'll get right you know they'll be
back in time we just gotta you know hold
the fourth down till those guys come
back
we'd be all right man just we got we
literally got to take it one day one
game at a time
play the way that we know how to play
you know you know form a little bit more
consistency out there on the court night
in the night out
we'll be fine carmelo shack here he had
some flashbacks tonight i've never been
the shooter
could you explain to me how it feels
when you hit one two or three in a row
how's it feel
just going you you're just going uh
you're playing ball you're in the rhythm
uh you're i'm a rhythm guy man so i i
get a rhythm i start feeling good and
the basket is big
it's the ball was going in tonight mello
you played absolutely amazing in that
quarter
and for me what does it mean to you that
they trust you so much in those
positions
that's that make or break time in the
game and they give it to you
i mean that trust is a big thing i can
tell you that you know for those guys to
trust me in these in these moments these
situations
at the end of the day it is basketball
though you know i know how to play
basketball i try to play the right way
uh you know it is a different situation
for me uh but i got to take advantage of
my opportunities and
that's what i'm going to continue doing
well i just want to say number one you
were awesome tonight but let me
i can tell you when i had those
flashbacks late in my career
you're going to be tired for the rest of
the week you know that don't you no i'm
good i'm good i'm in the shop
a glass of wine you're gonna be fine man
yeah yeah i gotta go i got a good glass
waiting for me tonight uh-oh
what's that chosen family i'll let you
know
season night 24 for carmelo anthony as
portland beats philly for the second
time in a week
118-114 thank you mello we appreciate it
and we welcome